Por qué la mitad de la población que
estaba llamada las urnas no acudió a
ellas
podría ser la nota sobresaliente del
proceso Más allá de los resultados y de
quiénes van a la segunda vuelta
electoral que evidentemente también es
quizás una segunda nota yo creo que este
proceso ha sido el más cuestionado
ha tenido
evidentemente más señalamientos de toda
la historia política del país hay que
remontarse a que la primera elección de
esta denominada transición época
democrática fue en el año 85 y en cada
lección Por supuesto que tiene sus
desafíos sin embargo este evento ha sido
inclusive mucho antes del proceso de
formalmente de inicio que fue el 20 de
enero Pues el arranque formal planteado
por el tribunal supremo electoral desde
por lo menos un año antes se establecía
una serie de señalamientos y
cuestionamientos uno por el por el
perfil de los partidos de la poca
digamos capacidad de poco contenido de
los partidos también de los candidatos
la una buena cantidad de candidatos que
hoy tenemos y que fueron inscritos que
pasaron supuestamente ese filtro por
parte del registro de ciudadanos son
bastante cuestionados inclusive tenemos
ahí personas que forman parte los
estados de aplicación del gobierno de
Estados Unidos de la ley magnifica o
listado Engel tenemos candidatos que
provienen que están en esos listados
muchos involucrados en actos de
corrupción un nivel de involucramiento
también del narcotráfico y de otras
redes criminales absolutamente muy
fuerte y por supuesto que una nota que
es que fue clave es el hecho de que tres
binomios o que querían ser binomios
presidenciales de tres partidos
diferentes finalmente no lograron ser
inscritos por elementos de orden
político inclusive uno de ellos había ya
logrado ser inscrito tenía la las
credencial estaba siendo campaña y hace
más o menos un mes fue sacado digamos de
la contienda ese tipo de elementos que
plantean un alto nivel de arbitrariedad
son parte de los factores que hacen que
este proceso para muchos guatemaltecos
termine representando poco o nada y da
como resultado que el porcentaje de Voto
nulo que pudiéramos tener en esta
elección sería de pronto el más alto de
la historia política del país también
acompañado del porcentaje de la menor
participación en una primera vuelta
electoral por supuesto que está todavía
lejos estamos todas no tenemos
tendencias estamos todavía comenzando a
recibir datos Pero uno podría dibujar
anticipadamente que algo de esto pudiera
confirmarse en los siguientes horas